[Musica]
c 15 16 17 18 19 e 20
bene sia cielo sono contento ora vorrei
sapere una cosa da tutti voi quanti
passi avete fatto per arrivare fin qui
beh c'è chi avrà percorso migliaia di
chilometri
chi addirittura è partito a giorni fa e
chi invece è sì bisogna dire che questo
più fortunato aveva la sveglia
stamattina alle 8 attraversato la città
o piazza de ferrari qui dietro e ora è
qui davanti quel che conta è che vi
siete messi in cammino per venire oggi
qui altre tex di genova e io adesso vi
chiedo da quando siete partiti fino
adesso
quanti passi avete fatto
quanti a ecco vedo gialli in fondo che
sia tenendo fuori il cellulare per
sbalordirvi col numero esatto di passi
frequenza ai chilometri percorsi veste
la sua app appena giornata ma va bene lo
stesso
quel che conta è che è quel numerino
indicato sul display
non è un semplice numero è energia pura
ok rappresenta infatti l'energia che voi
avete impiegato per venire fin qui ed è
un'energia pulita e green e duratura
guardatemi state quelli simpatici che vi
suggerisco che la chiamerei una fonte di
energia rinnovabile come dici come il
sole esatto brava proprio come il sole i
nostri passi sono energia
noi stessi siamo energia non siamo forse
fatti della stessa sostanza delle stelle
è bene e dopo tanti e tanti passi e
anche nei percorsi molti dalla mia amata
isola prevenire fin qua
eccoci qui sala delle grida una sala a
ricadi storia illuminata da quei
riflettori
voi potete sentire la mia voce grazie a
qui si altoparlanti e io vi parlo da
questo microfono ma scusate un attimo
123456789
ma un attimo che alimenta tutta questa
strumentazione
certo se lo scoprisse ma in questo
momento potremmo non essere tanto
contenti
oggi infatti la maggior parte
dell'energia deriva da fonti
combustibili ovvero petrolio e carbone
pensate per fare un chilowattora di
energia le centrali elettriche sputano
nell'aria 410 grammi della co2
dell'unione carbonica
ora siccome sono un ingegnere un po nerd
vi dico che è una molecola di co2
pesa tanto per capirlo facciamo insieme
un esperimento viva perfetto quindi
consideriamo un solido un cubo un cubo
di un metro cubo perfetto all'interno
mettiamo un sacchetto di sabbia nera che
pesa circa due chili
quello che abbiamo appena fatto e
costruirci il modello che rappresenta la
densità della co2 che appunto è pari a
1.98 kg a metro cubo ragazzi è un fatto
che la faccia così spaventata
sembra che mi state dicendo alessio ma
scusami un attimo c'è un ingegnere per
nulla ma da quando la co2
pesa da quando l'aria ha un peso
strano vero e io vi dico invece che solo
ragionando in termini di grandi numeri
possiamo capire quale sia il peso della
co2 ei danni che questa reca al mondo
che ci circonda
ora premetto che non voglio essere il
professore bacchettone che vi fa la
lezioncina sulla co2
tutti sappiamo infatti benissimo come un
aumento della co2 e comporta un aumento
della temperatura scioglimento dei
ghiacciai quindi condizioni stabili
tutto il mondo e ripercussioni a livello
globale
tutti lo sappiamo questo quindi dei
danni
riconoscete questo evento 13 luglio 2014
finale dei mondiali di calcio disputati
in brasile punteggio finale 1 a 0 per la
germania conta argentina voi l'avete
vista questa partita vero che la vista
sulle mani coraggio anch'io l'ho vista
questa partita
un sacco di gente l'ha visto nel mondo
oltre un miliardo di telespettatori
assistito a questo evento
quello però che non tutti sanno è che
questa partita ha portato ad
un'emissione di co2 nell'atmosfera di
150.000 tonnellate ovvero 150 milioni di
kg di co2
quindi parecchi di quei sacchettini di
stabia nella che abbiamo appena citato
caspita non posso neanche svagarmi
un'ora e mezza guerra una partita che
producono co2 pure ci deve essere una
soluzione per uscire da questa impasse
caspita ma fermi tutti ma non abbiamo
detto prima che i nostri passi solo
energia
ecco la soluzione i nostri passi era
proprio sotto i nostri piedi utilizzare
una fonte alternativa impensabile come i
nostri passi per produrre energia
elettrica pulita
ecco come si sentiva prometeo dopo che
ha rubato il fuoco agli dei per darla
noi umani i passi sono la soluzione
ora però bisogna capire come trovare un
sistema che ci permette quindi di
imbrigliare questa energia pulita quindi
estrarla dei nostri passi incanalarla e
utilizzarla per quello che più ci piace
fare trovato un pavimento un pavimento o
intelligente formato da mattonelle
intelligenti che trasformano ogni nostro
passo in energia pulita
ecco il nostro contributo per risolvere
l'aumento del fabbisogno energetico del
mondo e per ridurre la co2 a una
semplice mattonella intelligente tutto
qui
ora sebbene noi siamo in autunno
inoltrato in sì un pochino a fare
freschetto vorrei invitarvi mettete una
giacchina a fare un giretto sulla mia
delorian parcheggiata acqua fuori
guidata dal mio amico il professor brown
e ci facciamo un viaggio nel tempo fino
al 21 marzo 2017
inizia la primavera ea vera vuol dire
risveglio della natura risveglio della
vita
i ghiacci si sciolgono la vegetazione
torna a fiorire e un caldo vento di
cambiamento avvolge tutto e ci fa
dimenticare il freddo che sta arrivando
di voi hanno capito di certo dal mio
accento quali siano le origini mie e di
questa mattonella che produce energia e
bene entrambi arriviamo dalla sardegna
una terra che è rimasta per la maggior
parte esser selvaggia e incontaminata è
come potete vedere green e verde
se volete trovarmi nella mia città che
sta proprio sotto nel golfo degli angeli
h a cagliari da subito vi renderete
conto di una cosa potete ammirare
distese di campi eolici e di pannelli
fotovoltaici che producono energia
pulita energia verde guardate mi viene
da dire che è nei sardi abbiamo le
rinnovabili nel sangue ebbene in questa
terra baciata dal sole e dal mare dove
scusatemi se ve lo dico ma è sempre
primavera si sta troppo bene
nasce questa mattonella intelligente che
rappresenta tutta la voglia che abbiamo
oggi noi giovani di spiccare il volo di
guardare in alto e di spingerci al di là
di ogni limite
ebbene questa primavera di cui vi ho
appena parlato e appunto lei è questa
mattonella ora no torna ingegnere quindi
devo dare un giusto nome alle cose
quindi questa primavera è una tecnologia
una tecnologia che sta sotto le
mattonelle sulle quali tutti camminiamo
per andare all'università per andare
alle poste anche a mangiarsi un gelato
qui in piazza de ferrari e ogni nostro
passo grazie a lei viene trasformato in
energia
alessio scusa un attimo ma che
diavoleria se andando a raccontare al
ted quella che ti arrestano ciò che
permette ad una semplice scatola di
produrre energia secci cammino sciopera
e quindi di diventare magica è quella
proprietà fisica chiamata
piezoelettricità piezoelettricità
elettricità ora chi tra voi ha fatto e
sta facendo studi classici può a questo
punto vantarsi con la ragazza seduta
accanto ti invito a farlo di conoscere
il significato etimologico della parola
e devo dire che
si parla da ingegneri e che fratto liceo
classico stavolta il famigerato greco
finalmente ci viene in aiuto
piezoelettricità infatti deriva dal
greco ps in che vuol dire premere mentre
l'elettricità elettricità
sappiamo tutti cosa no di elettricità
uniamo le due parole è boom ci troviamo
nel 1880 laboratorio dei fratelli curi
pr e jack i primi che studiando il
quarzo scoprire un effetto
piezoelettrico torna infatti notarlo
come schiacciando questo materiale che
poi il quarzo il primo piezoelettrico
della storia notarlo come questo
risponde a secondo una corrente con
appunto energia
ecco quindi che ha la piezoelettricità
permette a lei di trasformare i nostri
passi in energia pulita è cosa di bello
questa energia pulita e duratura
la fonte che la genera come ormai
abbiamo capito è la più rinnovabile che
esista sulla faccia di questa terra e
sono quindi i nostri i nostri passi ora
capite perché prima a me premeva tanto
sapere quanti passi indicava il vostro
pedometro bene adesso ricapitoliamo o
come dicevano i latini repetita iuvant
quindi la nostra mattonella mischino per
chiamare sempre molto nella glielo diamo
un nome a questa mattonella dunque
rappresenta la prima vera all'interno a
componenti molleggianti elastiche direi
che si sbrighi spingi va bene spring in
inglese vuol dire infatti sia primavera
che molla quindi è un perfetto nome
parlante per la nostra cara amica bene
promossa anzi battezzata spring e quindi
la nostra spring è una tecnologia
totalmente integrabile nella
pavimentazione tradizionale sia essa
ceramica linoleum moquette o parquet e
trasforma ogni nostro passo in
elettricità in energia per effetto
piezoelettrico la sua stessa struttura e
amica dell'ambiente
spring infatti è realizzata con
materiali riciclati che non solo
riducano la co2 mani abbattono il costo
di produzione e quindi anche il costo il
prezzo al cliente finale
spring è una tecnologia a basso impatto
ambientale quasi nullo ed è appunto una
scatola spessa a pochi cm 43 dimensioni
di 30 x 30 cm e ha una superficie sulla
quale io fisso il pavimento tradizionale
che può abbassarsi sollevarsi di 2 mm
se ci cammina sopra e trasmette la
pressione al pizzo elettrico che sta
dentro ad ogni passo spring sprigiona 2
watt di potenza mentre l'energia del
accumulata in batteria
ora che bello categoria come potrei io e
potremmo noi godere di spring i io
personalmente amo ascoltare la musica è
se ci fosse un modo per ricaricare mille
trame p3 senza dover stare sempre in
casa a cercare la presa per attaccarmi a
ricaricare mi farebbe comodo che alla
fine beneficerà di lei potrà impiegare
l'energia prodotta come meglio crede per
esempio per illuminare una piazza per
ricaricare cellulari che sono sempre
scarichi per alimentare un modem wifi
modo tale da avere internet in tutta la
nostra città e anche per alimentare
questi schermi per dare informazioni
ovviamente a chi passa davanti
spingi verrà installata in maniera molto
facile grazie alle sue piccole
dimensioni o sul massetto o direttamente
sul pavimento tradizionale e su di essa
posso mettere come in questo caso della
ceramica in questo modo
vediamo spring invisibile e può quindi
essere installata in una piazza al
centro storico senza deturpare il
paesaggio o modificare l'urbanistica
primi è sotto è intelligente rispetto ad
altri perfetto spring inoltre può essere
installata quindi come ho detto abbiamo
ormai capito i luoghi molto affollati
come una piazza un centro commerciale un
aeroporto poiché più persone ci sono e
maggiore energia che questa scatola
magica può tirar fuori
pensate con solo 20 passi spring può
accendere i lampioni a luci led
e se mettessimo lei in piazza de ferrari
con tutti i cittadini che ci passano
tutta la giornata la sera potremmo
eliminare con la stessa piazza e in
questo modo il comune di genova potrebbe
avere un risparmio sui costi associati
all'illuminazione e anche ridurre la co2
in un centro commerciale invece spinge
può aprirmi e chiudere le porte
scorrevoli ora quello che a me viene da
suggerirvi oggi alte rics qui a giovan a
qui a genova scusate è semplicemente di
essere consapevoli di una cosa poi con i
vostri passi
potete andare dappertutto e ogni vostro
passo ricordate bene a dell'energia
noi da soli accendiamo una luce ma in
migliaia possiamo illuminare una piazza
una cosa molto bella questa
ora io vi svelo un segreto c'era un bel
segreto ovunque vada conto sempre i miei
passi
ma per sapere a quanti passi sono
arrivato finora beh questo è il numero
ora farò ingegnere ma riesce un po
difficile leggerlo velo leggere
volentieri si sono sapessi come si fa
credo che mary poppins e il suo cellino
siano gli unici che sappiano leggere il
numero con un supercalifragilistic a in
mezzo però io non ce la faccio
pertanto se voi oggi vorrete ricordarvi
di me come dello speaker dei passi dei
miliardi di milioni di miliardi pass per
me va bene anzi ne andrò molto fiero è
una cosa per me che piace a voi dovete
sapere dei passi e sono sicuro che molti
di voi appena uscirò da qua inizieranno
a contare passi e già mi immagino qui
camminando in strada che li contatta e
14 15 16 17 18 19 e 20 ok lo acceso o
123 ripresa contare
ed è così che deve essere quindi
ricordate i passi i passi sono ciò che
permettono ad una città di cambiare il
volto di dargli energia i passi sono il
futuro e ora io vorrei sapere una cosa
da voi vediamo se mi avete seguito fino
a questo punto mi avete osservato e
siete quindi dei bravi osservatori
quanti passi ho fatto io su questo
appello della rossa
mette del suo prodotto dai coraggio io
vi ringrazio
d ciao
troppo buoni grazie
[Applauso]